ce régime particulier et pour conclure
vous dire que c'est la culture est
universelle
votre retraite ne l'est pas je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président je vais
évoquer des arguments similaires à ce
qui a déjà été évoqué au préalable le
rapport démographique pour donc c'est un
régime qui qui 1 336 bénéficiaires de
droit direct 99 de droits dérivés 349
cotisants une dépense de 6 millions
d'euros sur lequel trois millions
s'assumer par par l'état donc comme
notre engagement nous avons vocation à
intégrer tous les régimes particuliers
donc c'est ce que nous voulons faire don
défavorable à cette suppression des
lumières je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
même avis monsieur le président merci
merci monsieur le président je suis
désolé monsieur le président pour toute
à l'heure mon coup de colère mais c'est
compliqué de de parler à ton avec merci
monsieur le président le vous l'avez dit
vous-même monsieur le rapporteur ça
concerne moins de 500 personnes et c'est
ces 500 personnes là participe au
patrimoine culturel français dans le
monde
c'est grâce à ces personnes là et je
vous dis en plus laissez pas forcément
les comédiens puisque continue à jouer
très tard c'est c'est vraiment pour ces
techniciens cetc costumière dont on m'a
parlé qui vont refaire un ourlet dans le
noir à dans l'arrière scène
c'est pour toutes ces personnes qui
avaient un petit une petite compensation
un petit remerciement de leur dire merci
grâce à vous la culture française passe
les frontières mais c'est notre fierté
et en remerciement de tous ces travaux
c'est à dire des montées quatre décors
par jour c'est à dire faire des ourlets
dans le noir le maquiller 50 fois dans
des conditions parfois très périlleuse
pour que toujours ait lieu cette ce
savoir faire français de la comédie
française ça vaut vraiment le coup de
vingtenaires ce régime
je veux remercier les paroles si
monsieur le tilt oui madame fiat on est
très attentif et je crois qu'il faut pas
il faut pas vous tromper on est très
attentif et on
on aime aussi beaucoup la culture moi je
voudrais ce problème des régimes
spéciaux je voudrais pour faire avancer
les débats et pour essayer de discuter
avec tous ensemble je voudrais le
renverser comment réagirions-nous
comment réagirions nous si un métier qui
est assez récents qui a une profession
qui est assez récente qui fait rayonner
la france à travers le monde qui a une
démographie en ce moment extrêmement
favorable venez nous dire aujourd'hui
nous voudrions avoir un régime spécial
je pense au rugby professionnel
voilà le rugby professionnel aujourd'hui
c'est une démographie extrêmement
positive nous sommes d'accord ça fait
rayonner la france j'espère que ça leur
fera rayonner encore plus dans quelques
années
et si aujourd'hui devant la
représentation nationale nous avons des
gens qui venaient nous dire écoutez
regardez nous on est beaucoup on a plein
de jeunes on n'a pas beaucoup de
retraités nous on voudrait avoir un
régime spécial et c'est un métier dur
c'est un métier difficile
c'est un métier risqué et comment
réagirions-nous comment réagirions-nous
je veux remercier fadoq prise de parole
pendant que passer au vote ne passant
directement au scrutin je vous prie de
regagner vos places sur l'amendement 10
8 763 le scrutin va s'ouvrir
le scrutin est ouvert il est clos
50 de votants 50 à exprimer majorité à
26 pour 8 contre 42 il est donc rejeté
nous passons à l'amendement 32 66
messieurs les rapporteurs monsieur guy
fischer monsieur le ministre
donc à travers cet amendement nous
parachevant l'universalité du nouveau
système de retraite en y intégrant
justement les sociétaires de la comédie
française qui pour le moment sont
laissés de côté par la rédaction
originel du projet de loi ce que le
conseil d'état avait lui même remarqué
le talent l'engagement l'héritage
historique porté par les sociétaires de
la comédie française sont reconnues par
tous et par tous et vous l'avez ici même
les uns et les autres connues y compris
les talents de l'ensemble des personnels
des agents qui travaillent à la comédie
française
que ce soit les costumières que ce soit
les agents qui travaillent à sarcelles
dans les ateliers des décors que ce soit
les techniciens parisiens
néanmoins la couverture de l'ensemble
des assurés quel que soit leur statut
leur métier leur fonction est au
fondement de l'engagement pris par le
président de la public en 2017 et porté
par cette majorité devant les français
aussi
il faut intégrer les sociétaires qui
sont au nombre de 40 la comédie
française dans le régime universel je
m'en remet d'ailleurs à la devise de la
comédie-française simul et singulis être
ensemble et rester soi même c'est
précisément le sens de cette intégration
dans le système universel jour merci
merci
monsieur le ministre quel est votre avis
monsieur le président il sera porteur
mesdames messieurs les députés sur le
sujet de la commune i française
s'il faut lui permettre de rester elle
même je pense que il faut qu'on puisse
lui donner un petit peu de temps et je
vais m'en expliquer la pension
statutaire des sociétaires ne ressemble
en fait à aucun type de retraite que
nous avons pu examiner aujourd'hui cave
c'est en fait une indemnité de départ
pour les sociétaires qui ne sont pas
salariés et qui d'ailleurs n'ont pas
droit au chômage
le gouvernement est favorable monsieur
le rapporteur général à l'affiliation
des sociétaires au système universel n'y
a pas d'ambiguïté dans mon propos et
pour permettre le renouvellement de la
troupe
il faut continuer à couvrir les départs
avant que n'intervienne l'âge de la
retraite et je vous propose de laisser
se tendent expertise qui est nécessaire
d' expertise approfondie pour définir un
nouveau dispositif qui soit adaptée la
situation des sociétaires qui vous sont
chers et que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure et aussi et vous savez c'est
l'ambition du gouvernement qu'ils soient
concertés avec eux en conséquence
monsieur rapporteur général
mesdames messieurs les députés je vous
demande générale de retirer votre
amendement et mesdames messieurs les
députés de laisser le temps nécessaire à
la concertation avec les sociétaires de
la comédie française et je prends
l'engagement devant vous ici de déposer
un amendement lorsque le texte viendra
au sénat pour pouvoir traiter de ce
sujet complètement dans l'esprit de ce
que vous venez de déposer déposer devant
nous monsieur le rapporteur général
donc mon avis c'est une demande de
retrait et à défaut sera défendra que
vous puissiez laisser le temps à cette
concertation qui a débuté à la comédie
française de s'achever dans de bonnes
conditions
monsieur l'un porteur et il retire et
hop un merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
nous en avons parlé vous savez que je
suis attaché au fait que les sociétaires
rentrer dans le régime universel pour la
question de l'universalité même du
système que nous mettons en place est
également pour l'enjeu d'unités de la
comédie française elle même puisque à la
comédie-française effectivement il n'ya
pas que les sociétaires il y à
l'ensemble des agents travaillent et qui
forme une même maison
il est important de maintenir ses notes
cette unité maintenant j'entends
effectivement ce que vous dites sur le
fait qu'il y à des discussions en cours
et qu'il faut prendre quelques semaines
de plus laissé quelques semaines de plus
pour que ces discussions aboutissent et
je pense que nous pouvons laisser ce
temps à cette magnifique institution qui
fait la fierté de notre pays et même
bien au delà aussi
j'accepterai vu l'engagement qui est
pris que vous déposiez vous même cet
amendement au sénat de retirer mon
amendement je vous remercie les donc
retiré nous pourrons passer à la maman
18 880 identique pour lequel je suis
saisi par le groupe la france ont mis la
france d'un saut mise d'un scrutin
public que nous annonçons dans cette
enceinte
18 780 vous suivez attentivement je vous
en remercie je vous en remercie bien
allons-y 18 780 qu'il défend madame
fiable vous avez la parole ah oui c'est
important
merci monsieur le président donc par cet
amendement nous souhaitons supprimés
l'alinéa 13 et maintenir aux ouvriers
des établissements industriels de l'état
leur régime spécial
comme tous les régimes que nous faisons
depuis cet après-midi tout simplement
enfin je vais pas vous réécrire
l'histoire à chaque fois ci a bien fait
gym spécial c'est que à un moment donné
il y a bien eus
comment une décision prise pour
justifier le fait d'un régime spécial et
pour le collègue petit qui tout à
l'heure me parlait des exemples des
rugbymans c'était au tout début
c'est au jeu bien qu'on revienne au
début de nos discussions de la semaine
dernière méchant vous allez me dire que
vous n'avez pas envie que vous voulez
avancer ce texte mais on a eu toutes ces
discussions sur les sportifs de haut
niveau
on a parlé de tout ça je veux bien qu'on
fasse le débat monsieur petit mas près
vous allez après vous allez vous allait
m'accuser de faire de l'obstruction
et alors donc on va pas revenir sur le
débat mais la discussion a eu lieu sur
les sportifs de haut niveau
je vous remercie nous passons aux 25 183
qu'il défend qu'il défend groupe
socialiste 25 183 défendu je remercie
très bien défendu 26 756 monsieur
dufresne vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président ce cet
amendement vise la suppression de
l'alinéa 13 de cet article et la
préservation du fonds spécial des
pensions des ouvriers des établissements
industriels
les personnels sous statut ouvrier de
l'état du ministère des armées du
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire et de ses établissements
publics du ministère des finances du
ministère de l'intérieur s'inquiète de
votre réforme qui menace de façon
particulièrement grave
le niveau de leurs pensions et les
conditions de départ des futurs
retraités
intégration du calcul de la pension à
partir de l'ensemble des salaires perçus
tout au long de la carrière augmentation
des taux de cotisation salariale
retraite de 11 10 à 11 25% remise en
cause du dispositif de départ anticipé
des ouvriers de l'état dans le cadre des
travaux insalubres les annonces de
l'intégration du régime indemnitaire
dans l'assiette de cotisation ne sont
pas à leurs yeux une mesure de
compensation suffisante
tous les cordes ouvriers de l'état ne
sont en effet pas soumis un régime
indemnitaire identique est par ailleurs
ceci cotisent déjà sur la majeure partie
du régime indemnitaire et sur les aires
les heures supplémentaires pour les
ouvriers d'état le risque est avéré
d'une accentuation de la précarité
à l'occasion de la mise en oeuvre de
votre réforme
c'est pourquoi nous demandons le
maintien de leur régime de retraite
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
quel est votre avis
merci monsieur le président j'ai pas
tout à fait compris madame fiat à quel
camp vous faisiez référence aux sportifs
de haut niveau concernant les ouvriers
d'état ou alors l'examen du texte c'est
en tous les cas là pour l'instant nous
sommes plutôt à l'examen en mode si on
était des sportifs mode marathon avec au
moins rangers sow pied sur les ouvriers
d'état même réflexion mais peut-être pas
suivi excusez moi sur sur l'importance
et l'attention particulière aux ouvriers
d'état je ne peux que partager votre
analyse monsieur monsieur dufrègne jeu
j'ai même découvert un certain nombre de
métiers exercés par cette profession
enfin cette catégorie très particulière
il faut là encore avec la même logique
aujourd'hui c'est 24000 cotisants pour
cent mille pensionnés environ 24000
cotisants essentiellement qui dépendent
du ministère des armées dans les
arsenaux mais pas que on en trouve eu un
petit peu partout dans les fonctions
dans des fonctions d'état
donc il faut avoir une attention
particulière mais là encore vu la
démographie du régime
prévoir une intégration prévoir une
intégration en rapport avec leurs
caractéristiques que spécifique donc de
savoir
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
donc même avec leur apportant même alain
jacques attristé par le monsieur
cazeneuve petit bernalicis et genicot
oui mais merci monsieur le président je
voudrais juste dire à queue évidemment
nous ne souhaitons stigmatiser personne
bien au contraire et on peut
parfaitement comprendre que pour tous
les régimes spéciaux dont on parle
maintenant lié à l'origine ya 80 ans où
il ya un siècle que fois un peu plus de
vraies bonnes raisons pour avoir un
régime un régime spécifique et je sais
aussi que un certain nombre de ses
collaborateurs qui ont des expertises
très forte souffre d'ailleurs de l'image
qu'il donne
elle vous voudriez pas toujours des
experts des ingénieurs des comédiens et
il souffre quelquefois de l'image que ça
que ça renvoie et des fantasmes
d'ailleurs que peuvent créer quelques
fois ces régimes je crois qu en les
intégrant dans le régime universel on
coupe court à tous ses fantasmes trois
bénéfices le premier c'est celui là le
deuxième c'est qu'on a prévu
je crois que c'était la moindre des
choses je crois que c'est extrêmement
respectueux une phase de transition
extrêmement longues qui va être vu avec
chacun de ses métiers avec les
organisations syndicales et qui va
apporter je suis sûr toutes les
garanties puis le troisième point c'est
que souvent ces régimes sont
déficitaires et donc on pérennise
évidemment les retraites dans le temps
une petite remarque aussi à défendre
ironique il y à défendre tous les
régimes spéciaux je pense à la banque de
france qui a agi à régime par
capitalisation injuste je le précise
pour ceux qui l'auraient oublié et on
voit bien toute la beauté du système
universel qui va réunir 100 % des
français avec un système plus simple
plus juste plus plus sociale merci je
vous remercie monsieur bernalicis merci
monsieur le président à préciser tout
d'abord que ma collègue carl une fête
répondait aux collègues petit tout à
l'heure qui disait vis-à-vis de la
comédie française
et si les rugbyman professionnel il
fallait leur crée un régime etc c'est
pour que le rapporteur soit bien suivre
nos débats pour revenir ici sur les
ouvriers des tares qui nous occupe oui
vous avez dit collègues collaborateurs
et ses ouvriers on parle des ouvriers
d'état spa vous pouvez dire que les
collaborateurs et nier leur statut qui
est une fierté pour eux pour toutes et à
tous parce que ce sont des travailleurs
qui ont des hautes compétences manuelles
et intel est donc intellectuelle
également évidemment la démographie
n'est pas bonne monsieur le rapporteur
évidemment la démographie n'est pas
bonne de ce régime pourquoi parce que
l'état n'a de cesse de ne plus ouvrir de
postes au concours des ouvriers d'état
depuis des années déjà on a tué ce corps
et après vous arriver là tranquillement
en disant oui mais regardez la
démographie n'est pas bonne mais il ne
tient qu'à vous ouvrez des postes vous
aurez des ouvriers d'état et vous aurez
une démographie splendide permettant
d'avoir des actifs qui paye les
retraités et une caisse qui ne soit plus
déficitaires et cet exemple de caisses
déficitaires d'un point de vue
démographique
elle est souvent due à la volonté
politique et par un état de la
démographie en soi a donc attention
monsieur le rapporteur aux arguments que
vous avancez car souvent ils vous sont
plutôt défavorables en réalité
quant à leur régime en tant que tel qui
soit spéciale nous l'avons dit à maintes
reprise
oui nous assumons une part de solidarité
nationale et l'hérésie spéciaux en font
partie vous vous n'assumez qu'une chose
un dogmatisme idéologique qui est de
dire tout le monde doit être dans le
régime universel par principe
en dépit de la réalité en dépit de la
réalité et nous ne pourrons jamais
accepter ce mode de fonctionnement
dogmatique qui n'apporte aucun argument
sur la table qui me permettent de
justifier une politique telle que celle
que vous conduisez je vous remercie
monsieur johnny cause de la parole ce
président derrière chaque régimes
spéciaux
il y a une histoire une histoire sociale
c'est le produit d'une histoire sociale
produits de mouvement ouvrier et les
ouvriers d'état ça compte dans le pays
ce sont les héritiers de la manufacture
d'armes à l'époque fin du 19e siècle à
saint-etienne 10 mille ouvriers 9000
machine qui fabrique l effort de guerre
les fusils pas ce qui a permis à la
france aussi de se défendre mais aussi
plus tard le fameux famas peut-être que
certains l'ont lomagne et au service
militaire
ici sur ces bancs et donc effectivement
des ouvriers qui avaient une très très
grande technicité de très grand savoir
faire mais qui était effectivement des
ouvriers l'étape qui était dans le cadre
d'une industrie bien particulière qui
est l'armement terrestre pas simplement
à l'armement terrestre il en ya encore
aujourd'hui des beaux restes
je pense puisque j'ai hâte a disparu et
que maintenant c'est une entreprise qui
s'appelle l'ex terre à lusine de roanne
qui aujourd'hui reconditionne les
véhicules blindés et qui a produit
beaucoup de chars leclerc qui permettent
à nos troupes en particulier aux
militaires français de pouvoir aussi
défendre les valeurs de la france aux
quatre mois au cours des seuls collègues
cerner connexes dix histoires aussi
dramatique puisque c'est une histoire de
reconversion une histoire de
réindustralisation qui fait que
l'armement terrestre dans les années 90
dans les années 2000
bien évidemment les commandes ont baissé
et beaucoup ont été pris dans des
restructurations ont été reconvertis
dans d'autres missions dans d'autres
métiers et on leur doit le respect et je
pense que ce soit effectivement ce
régime spécial
il faut que l'on puisse le saluer et lui
dire toute notre reconnaissance aussi au
nom de l'histoire deux pays je vous
remercie
oui monsieur pain voudrais quand même
pas dresser un portrait aussi noircir
nous ouvriers sur notre savoir-faire
monsieur bernalicis de notre compétence
et de notre excellence française du
travail de la manufacture du verre de la
haute couture
on a quand même les ouvriers qui
travaillent très bien qu'ils ont un vrai
savoir faire un savoir faire qu'on
exporte c'est quand même notre plus
grande richesse et et tout ce qui se
crée actuellement dans au niveau de
l'apprentissage et tout fonds est la
preuve que que qu'il ya du travail qui a
été acquis et qui a qu'il ya de l'avenir
dans ces métiers là et il faut vraiment
continuer d'avoir et puis sur le
l'armement industriel moi j'ai je vois
en face de chez moi à lorient il ya le
naval groupe naval groupe
ils ont du boulot pour 15 ans saison
donc vraiment je pense que tu as ton et
métiers qui ont su aussi comme le dit
souvent monsieur petit conçu aussi
peut-être évoluer avant on avait des
blagues pas toujours très sympa sur les
ouvriers de l'arsenal on a tous eu des
petites blagues dans nos coins sûr
et maintenant je pense que c'est des
vrais métiers des vrais savoir-faire et
ce sont des sources de création
d'entreprise voilà merci s'exprimer on
peut le faire nous pouvons donc passer
au vote je mets aux voix par scrutin
public je vous rappelle l'amendement 18
780 identique
vous avez regagner vos places scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
60 de votes en majorité à 30 pour 9
contre 49
ils sont donc rejeter l'amendement
suivant et le 14 99
nous avons un moment du scrutin public
par la france a soumis ce que nous
annonçons dans cet hémicycle 1 qui le
défend 99 et 14 99
merci monsieur and then merci beaucoup
monsieur le président il s'agit d'un
amendement de notre collègue bazin que
nous sommes certains quelques-uns avoir
cosigné cet amendement propose de
supprimer la linea relatifs aux
personnes travaillant dans les mines
alors que soit bien d'accord il s'agit
nullement de revenir en arrière
simplement le régime minier a déjà été
mise en extinction et ceci depuis
septembre 2010 donc il est en extinction
depuis dix ans et depuis cette date tous
les salariés qui sont embauchés le sont
bien entendu au régime général
on compte aujourd'hui moins de 1400
actifs et les derniers mineurs partiront
à la retraite à l'horizon 2040
donc là l'idée est très simple c'est que
en fait 2040 ces trois ans après la date
butoir de janvier 2037 prévue dans le
projet de loi est là on se dit que cet
amendement permettrait de finir leur
carrière roaming aux mines
comme prévu lors de leur embauche et
d'éviter des mesures de transition
simplement pour trois années parce
qu'encore une fois ce qui intervient
quand on procède à une
vers un nouveau régime en réalité il ya
des coûts de transaction
il ya des coûts de gestion et donc ce
que nous disons aujourd'hui la caisse
des dépôts et consignations qui est en
charge de ce régime fait ça très bien et
donc laissons cette fois ci ce régime
qui est déjà en extinction et bien
poursuivre sa vie et ne procédons pas là
a une vision dogmatique de volonté de
régime général
alors que entre 2037 et 2040 c'est à
dire trois ans après la question est
réglée
de toute façon je remercie je vous
remercie le 12 705 monsieur pas lu ce
qui évite ch pas défendu le 18 797 les
17 amendements identiques aux sommes
fiables
oui merci monsieur le président
l'amendement de mon collègue thibault
bazin rendant à césar ce qui est à césar
et est très bien écrit et il sait de
quoi il parle
c'est lui qui a les dernières mines avec
les mines du salines des sabines à
varangéville et il vous explique très
bien que trois ans il reste trois ans de
régimes de retraites à payer
quel est l'intérêt de tous modifiés pour
trois années
tout a déjà été modifié en 2010 et ça
s'arrête en 2040
donc là en fait votre date butoir est en
janvier 2000 37 alors que tout est déjà
arrêtée pour 2040
est ce que ça vaut le coup réellement
pour trois années pour les 1400 actifs
aujourd'hui de deux tours voire de tout
remettre à plat pour je le rappelle
trois années et c'est un dossier qui
inquiète beaucoup en meurthe-et-moselle
si je vous disais chez thibault bazin il
ya les salines de varangéville est un
peu partout en meurthe et moselle on a
encore quelques régime minier voilà
est-ce que monsieur le ministre pour
trois années
vous ne pouvez pas faire un geste et
dire qu'effectivement pour 1400
personnes sur trois ans peut-être il
n'est pas nécessaire de créer une usine
à gaz pour pour trois années mercy le 24
980 ne me semble pas défendu le 25 184
monsieur nico ya monsieur le président
je peux me donner l'impression de me
répéter sur la question du régime
spécial des mines des mineurs est mineur
de fond les derniers puis ont fermé en
83 84 les mineurs dardoise récemment
aussi fermé il reste les mineurs de sel
en meurthe-et-moselle et on l'a dit
c'est un régime spécial héritier et
produits de notre histoire 1946 nous
leur devons du respect mais ses 1400
cotisons là bien évidemment on va pas
supprimer leur régime spécial comme ça
du jour au lendemain et il ya deux cent
quarante mille aujourd'hui bénéficiaire
du régime de pension des mineurs soit
des anciens mineurs souvent dans un état
de santé dégradé bien évidemment
silicose si dire aux maladies
cardiovasculaires et puis aussi les
veuves des anciens mineurs et qui
touchent des pensions extrêmement faible
et qui sont souvent dans les situations
de précarité
alors il ya un bien une tentative il ya
quelques années de xavier bertrand quand
il était ministre la santé pour mettre
fin au régime spécial de sécurité
sociale et de gratuité des soins
deux des mineurs et tous les élus des
bassins miniers ici sur tous les bancs
se sont réunis pour s'y opposer nous
avons obtenu cette victoire on va
jusqu'au dernier ayant droit donc
faisons la même chose
jusqu'au dernier bénéficiaire jusqu'au
dernier mineur jusqu'à la dernière veuve
et laissons les tranquilles pour 1400
cotisants de toute façon je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui il est à dire je reprends le
1 milliard d'euros que soit disant cela
coûte aujourd'hui à la sécurité
nationale alors que nous devons c'est un
droit à réparation nous devons aux
mineurs de fond d'avoir recours c'est
notre pays et de nous avoir permis
d'être aujourd'hui
nous y sommes c'est à dire dans un pays
de liberté et relativement prospère sur
le plan économique et nous avons 16
amendements identiques qui les défend 26
841 monsieur brunet dans le même état
d'esprit que mes collègues notamment
demande on vise à défendre le régime
spécial des mineurs bien qu'un tel
régime puisse apparaître anachronique
130 mille retraités ils sont toujours
affilié ce qui fait de ce régime le 3ème
régiment termes de nombre de retraités
gym aussi emblématique est encore
centrale dans certaines régions on en a
parlé comme le nord de la france moi je
suis de la région de douai où il ya le
bassin minier avec lens etc
la lorraine ou dans le pays de la loire
donc il permettrait aussi aux mineurs de
pouvoir toucher une retraite dès 50 ans
donc jamais jusqu'à maintenant puisque
mon collègue vient de le dire un
gouvernement a supprimé un tel régime
spécial pour les travailleurs qui ont
souvent payé de leur vie de leur travail
au fond des puits régime des mineurs
coûte aujourd'hui pour tout mettre sur
la table près d'un milliard d'euros à
l'état
non pas parce que les mineurs profite de
ses conditions de départ avantage n est
pas ce qu il reste aujourd'hui 1400 à
1500 cotisants pour près de 130 mille
retraités affiliés à la caisse et le
passage dans le système universel ne
changera donc pas la donne à ce niveau
puisque faudra continuer à financer ce
régime spécial pour autant
en intégrant ces retraités vous risquez
de désorganiser la caisse autonome d'un
tigre et sociale dans l'âme dans la mine
au delà des pensions la caisse gère
également l'offre de soins complète et
gratuite avec la mise en place de
maisons de soins notamment pour les
affiliés qui sont aujourd'hui
essentiellement des veuves de mineurs en
intégrant à la hâte les affiliés de la
caisse des mineurs qui est pourtant en
extinction vous désorganiserait comme
l'animé mes collègues le fonctionnement
de la caisse qui reste toi donc pour
tous l'école déficitaire nous souhaitons
donc qu'il soit exclu
positive et devrait s'éteindre
naturellement dans les années à venir
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président j'entends
l'argument comme quoi les derniers
seraient concernés pour trois ans en
termes de 2,2 me à partir de 2030 7 pour
autant l'intégration régime universel
est à partir de 2025 et donc c'est le
faible nombre de cotisants vous avez
évoqué 1400 cotisants pour un peu plus
de 200 milles pensionnés on peut on peut
le comprendre mais c'est dès 2025 qui
vont progressivement intégré le régime
de retraite comme tous les autres tous
les autres actifs de france et puis je
dirais que c'est peut-être un petit peu
emblématique de la réforme qu'on veut
faire parce que finalement s'il ya plus
de mineurs aujourd'hui c'est que les
métiers ont évolué et ce qui était vrai
hier ne l'est plus ne l'est plus
forcément aujourd'hui et ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui ne sera plus forcément
demain en matière de structuration
d'emploi et que justement que les actifs
de demain payent pour les retraités de
demain
c'est le sens que tous les actifs
quelles que soient les métiers qu'on
puisse faire est et je trouve que de ce
point de vue là il ya un côté symbolique
que les mineurs même si c'est
extrêmement à la marge qui vont être
concernés puissent en faire partie comme
une forme de transmission et
d'intégration à la nation défaveur
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président oui monsieur
député monsieur et elle madame fiat
monsieur brunel j'entends vos arguments
vous nous dites sur le fond il reste
1400 cotisants est ce que il est
nécessaire de demander à ses 1400
cotisants d'intégrer le système
universel de retraite moi je suis assez
à l'aise avec la réponse du rapporteur
parce que il nous dit bon il ya une
volonté d'universalité s'agit pas
d'exclure les uns ou les autres
uniquement sur la seule base d'un effet
volume c'est pas le nombre qui fait
qu'on a des roues qu'on adhère pas on
est dans la collectivité nationale on
est
la nation et est à ce titre là nous nous
proposons à la représentation nationale
de s'exprimer sur un système universel
de retraite c'est pas la clé d'entrée ce
n'est pas le nombre qui fait les choses
c'est simplement la qualité qu'on a tous
s'affairent république ensemble et c'est
cela qui nous mobilise sur le fond donc
je voudrais juste redire qu une chose
d'abord parce que on vous écoute en
monsieur député bruel j'avais un peu
l'impression vous pensiez que nous
voulions remettre en cause les
conditions des 130 mille retraités et
les conditions de pensions pas du tout
les dispositions dispositif qui concerne
tous ceux qui ont leur retraite
aujourd'hui ne changeront pas donc on
n'a pas de questions qui se posent pour
ceux qui sont actuellement retraité et
je rappelle quand même pour le régime
des mines comme pour tout le monde que
lorsqu'on est à moins de 17 ans de la
retraite
on continue à cotiser dans le système
actuel où nous sommes et nous verrons
notre pension de retraite depuis qu'il
est sur la base des règles des
dispositifs actuels
bon donc voilà je pense que le
gouvernement là dessus est clair il dit
pour tous ceux qui soit plus de 17 ans
de la retraite est bien racontée 2025
qui cotiseront dans le système universel
de retraite et à ce titre là nous ferons
république tous ensemble pour tous ceux
qui sont à moins de 17 ans la retraite
ils continueront pour les raisons qu'on
a déjà évoqué ensemble dans cet
hémicycle à cotiser dans le système
actuel des vignes et seront verront leur
pension liquidée
selon les dispositifs en vigueur dans le
système des mines et puis pour tous les
retraités
rien ne changera et continuera à
percevoir leur retraite telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui est là dessus là pas
de souci voilà pourquoi sur le fond
j'avais envie de vous demander mesdames
messieurs les députés parce que je pense
que tu es plus un échange entre nous
peut-être plutôt de retirer votre
amendement parce que si l'inquiétude
portait sur les retraités actuels
on voit bien qu'il n'y en a pas si les
inquiétudes portaient sur ceux qui vont
être à quelques années de liquider leur
retraite y en a pas et sur le fond si
c'est pour ceux qui seront concernés par
ce qu'il soit plus de 17 ans de la
retraite
eh bien ils vont voir comme pour tous
les français un chemin de convergence se
construire
ils vont intégrer progressivement le
système universel
bon voilà je pense qu on est ici dans
une situation où c'est pas le nombre qui
fait le débat simplement le fait qu'on
soit tous ensemble dans cette société
est en égalité devant la retraite avis
défavorable s'il n'y a pas de retrait
monsieur le président je vous remercie g
d'inscrits et madame dalloz madame
esayan monsieur perea et monsieur
janicot pour l'instant et madame fiat
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre alors il ya une vérité déjà
tout d'abord je voudrais dire que
l'amendement de mon collègue thibault
bazin qui a été absent de constamment
depuis le début de du texte j'ai dix
absents nom qui a été construit fatigué
qui a été constamment présent depuis le
début du texte vous voyez comme quoi il
ya unanimité pour dire qu'il était
présent a dû repartir ce soir
malheureusement dans sa circonscription
et donc non pas dans sa mine de sel mais
dans sa circonscription et il est
sensible à ce sujet là mais je comprends
pourquoi la dernière mine de sel qui
restent en france
elle se trouve dans sa circonscription
la réalité c'est quoi je vous écoutez
monsieur le rapporteur et monsieur le
ministre alors les actifs on est tous
d'accord il y a aujourd'hui 1400 actif
dans le régime mais qui ne cotisent plus
dans le dispositif puisque ils sont
ressortissants
depuis 2010 il y avait une transition
ils sont dans le régime général les
actifs aujourd'hui de cette profession
sont dans le régime général ce qui reste
dans le dispositif se sont effectivement
les cent trente sept mille alors
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez dit 140
monsieur le ministre en 30 mois mes
documents me donne 137000 je sais pas où
est la précision utile 137000 cotisants
20 ressortissants de la caisse autonome
nationale de la sécurité sociale dans
les mines vouloir impérativement les
intégrer dans le système à points
universel c'est une vision dogmatique
vous venez de dire monsieur le ministre
tous ensemble il faut que rien ne
dépasse la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que
j'aimerais bien que vous me donniez le
coup monsieur le ministre du dispositif
nom du dispositif du basculement
justement parce que votre transition
votre période de transition
on s'était rappelée par monsieur
cazeneuve le député cazeneuve la période
de transition qui est extrêmement longue
il l'a dit tout à l'heure
2037 on l extinction programmée de ce
régime c'est 2040
quel est l'intérêt entre 2037 et 2040 de
faire de remettre en cause le dispositif
par rapport à l'existence
moi je ne comprends pas la vision que
vous puissiez avoir de tous derrière et
lui devant
ça me rappelle une poésie ou une chanson
pour enfants mais la réalité c'est que
dans le dispositif
s'il n'y a pas une exception une entorse
à la règle
s'il y a une particularité ou un
particularisme à prendre en compte c'est
celui des personnes qui travaillent dans
les mines
parce que là franchement je ne
comprendrais pas que vous générez
surcoût de transposition pour alors que
le régime c'est un en 2040
et je terminerai là dessus en disant qu
en 2010 justement il y avait eu un peu
de courage puisque ce régime avait été
inscrit dans la loi la réforme des
retraites pour son extinction
progressive et qu'en 2040 le régime
n'existera plus
je m'en excuse à nice et je remercie le
mal aux la parole et à madame est
saillant
monsieur le président à la la preuve que
tous ces régimes spéciaux non plus de
lisibilité aujourd'hui c'est que nous
sommes en train de décortiquer un par un
tantôt c'est les mineurs tantôt ses
employés au port autonome stress
pourtant tous les personnes qui
organisent le culte israélite entre ces
notaires notent aussi le personnel
artistique va ça n'a vraiment plus de
sens on se rend compte en fait
en vous écoutant que franchement on en
arrive aujourd'hui à un système qui n'a
plus de lisibilité qui n'a plus de sens
et qui est en train de nous diviser en
réalité au lieu de nous réunir et
c'était un an justement que ce soit vous
les communistes par exemple kiki
défendiez un système où nous soyons
aussi
séparés les uns des autres où finalement
cette solidarité réelle ne soit pas mise
en jeu pour que nous puissions nous
soutenir les uns les autres au lieu que
chacun fasse son petit son petit bazar
de son côté que la droite le veuille
c'est pas très étonnant elle dit ok on
fait un minima pour tout le monde et
puis après les gens se débrouillent
mais vous comment est ce que c'est
possible alors la france un
assouplissement c'est pas trop ce
qu'elle veut mais sa part de détruire un
peu les institutions et de faire je sais
pas quel modèle de société jamais
compris mais les communistes je
comprends vraiment pas alors vous
cherchez à nous diviser nous cherchons à
montrer de nous une image vous cherché à
montrer une image de nous de méchant là
qu'ils s'en fichent n'était plus petit
des plus fragiles alors que c'est
justement pour que nous faisons ce
système pour pouvoir les protéger c'est
automatique vous avez 10 et 12 mètres
absolument pas ce n'est pas dogmatique
justement la pénibilité va être vraiment
prise en compte dans notre système il
aura une vocation le fragile alors c'est
un système qui est beaucoup plus juste
que tout ce que j'entends actuellement
qui sera beaucoup plus solidaire plus
lisible oui il ya une phase de
transition oui il y aura des adaptations
à faire mais nous y faisons face et nous
nous permettons que justement les règles
du jeu ne soient pas changé en cours de
route alors que vous je sais pas très
bien ce que vous allez faire mais en
tout cas ça sera notre projet et il sera
bon merci je vous remercie
chers collègues
s'il vous plaît j'ai eu plusieurs
remarques
s'il vous plaît chers collègues j'ai eu
plusieurs remarques c'est plusieurs
remarques ce après midi de ne pas être
interpellé pendant qu'on parle c'est ce
qui vient justement de se passer donc on
va essayer toussaint de ça arrive tous à
un moment ou un autre on va essayer
juste de mener nos débats correctement
d'abord par respect par l'eau pour
l'orateur qui parle monsieur perea à
vous merci merci monsieur le président
je vous ai écouté j'ai écouté tout toute
la journée et notamment sur ces régimes
sur ces régimes spéciaux
j'ai écouté les arguments et d'abord je
voudrais dire que même si je ne suis pas
d'une région où il ya des mineures je
crois qu'on peut tous être d'accord pour
dire que le métier de la mine a
peut-être été dans l'histoire des
métiers les plus durs et pour ceux qui
le font encore ça reste encore un métier
très très dur mais ce que j'ai entendu
aussi tout au long de la journée dans
les arguments qui était avancée c'est
que ces régimes spéciaux est l héritage
est l héritage d'une histoire et l
héritage d'une culture
sauf que sauf que je voudrais avancer
sur trois éléments
le premier élément c'est que moi les
jeunes que je rencontre aujourd'hui ils
sont épris de carrière qui leur offrent
de la liberté il veut le pouvoir
travailler cinq ans dans un endroit
partir 2 1 en voyage revenir trois
annonces de notre métier changer de
métier se reformer et ses régimes
spéciaux
ces régimes spéciaux les rendre
prisonnier des métiers qu'ils ont
commencé à faire quand il était jeune
le deuxième élément qui m'a vraiment
choqué ce soir c'est quand on me dit oui
mais la retraite 1 est un élément
important pour que les jeunes
choisissent un métier moi pendant 15 ans
j'ai formé des jeunes à des entretiens
d'embauché
je n'ai jamais eu en face de moi un
jeune qui m'a posé la question quel va
être ma retraite ou qu'elle va être mon
système de retraite ils m'ont posé plein
de questions
vous pouvez prendre tous les ouvrages
sur les entretiens d'embauché
vous n'avez jamais cette question là qui
arrive et puis mettez vous en tant
qu'employeur si vous embauchez un jeune
de 20 ans qui vous pose comme question
quel sera mon système de retraite
est-ce que ça va être pour vous un
critère de recrutement en tout cas pour
moi
je trouve insultant d'avoir entendu cet
après midi que les jeunes cadres qui
rentrait à la sncf rentrer parce que
leur système de retraites était
avantageux le troisième et dernier point
que je voudrais dire et qui vient
vraiment sur cette question des mineurs
c'est que il y à quelques décennies on
ne savait pas soigner un certain nombre
de maladies et donc il fallait quand
même envoyé des gens je vais le dire
comme ça il fallait quand même envoyé
des gens au charbon et on en voyait déjà
en sachant que l'envié qu'ils allaient
avoir des maladies et un peu en échange
un jeu malheureusement on leur proposait
des retraites jeunes
mais comment aujourd'hui avec tous les
efforts qui ont été faits sur le
bien-être sur la santé comment peut-on
aujourd'hui continuer à dire à des gens
on vous envoie là on vous envoie là en
échange vous aurez une retraite plus
jeunes non mais si oui c'est de se
former nous ce qu'on propose c'est de
pouvoir changer de métier romain est
donc en faisant ce que vous faites vous
êtes les quatre mrc des progrès du passé
et donc vous êtes des gardiennes de la
régression sociale
monsieur juin et on vous avez la parole
de ces jeunes ico le président
j'aimerais qu'on ait un peu de respect
pour ce que représente l'histoire des
conquêtes sociales dans ce pays et en
particulier ce qu'ont apporté les
mineurs de fond dans le patrimoine de
nos propres conquêtes sociales 1886
grève à decazeville 1er mai 1891 fourmis
1892 carmaux ce sont les mineurs de fond
qui dans leurs luttes sociales et dans
leur grève nous ont permis de nous
interdire le travail des enfants de
limiter la journée à 8 heures de
construire tout le système de sécurité
sociale avant la sécurité sociale c'est
à dire la mutualité en particulier ça
venait des caisses des mineurs je dis ça
parce que il ya un pacte social qui a
été signé après la deuxième guerre
mondiale en 1946
entre la nation et les mineurs de fond
et moi je n'accepte pas le terme petit
bazar je ne l'acceptent pas parce que
nous devons le respect et nous devons a
droit à réparation par rapport à ces à
cette corporation là le régime de
sécurité sociale des mines
ces trois choses accidents du travail
les soins sécurité sociale et les
retraites
ces cent mille affiliés sur la sécurité
sociale et ses 240 milles encore
bénéficiaire du régime de pensions je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure ce sont des
anciens mineurs qui gagne très peu ce
sont des veuves de mineurs qui sont
souvent dans la précarité
tout un système a été construit après 46
de gratuité des soins avec des
pharmacies avec des médecins avec des
hôpitaux et c'était tout simplement la
contrepartie à la pénibilité au travail
et aussi à la mort telle mortalité tout
simplement des mineurs de fond qui était
au fond du trou et pas simplement qu'il
y avait un coup de grisou parce que
souvent c'était des maladies qui en suit
pas c'est que silicose si des roses et
maladies cardiovasculaires il beaucoup
sont morts d'ici là donc je veux dire
laissons ce régime allait jusqu'au bout
et nous rajoutons pas mais je le redis
vous ne supprimerait pas le régime
spécial des mines et vous continuerez
par la solidarité nationale
alors donné un milliard d'euros par an
c'est évident on clôt merci madame vous
avez la parole puis ce sera monsieur
brummel monsieur vigier
merci monsieur le président j'aurais
répondu volontiers à mes collègues modem
est en marche mais dès que nous faisons
un petit pâtre avec nous ne sommes pas
sur le moment on sait nous le rappeler
nous demander voir voir non non on sait
nous le rappeler donc je vais rester sur
mon amendement et parler des mines et
redire que 1400 actifs aujourd'hui et
donc on n'a pas dit que c'était comment
trois ans après votre mise en place
c'est que ce que dit très bien mon
collègue thibault bazin que leur site
parce qu'il l'a très bien écrit soit
trois ans après la date butoir de jeu de
janvier 2037 prévu dans ce projet de loi
les derniers mineurs partiront en
retraite donc en fait vous êtes en train
de créer un régime où des gens vont
perdre pour trois années pour très peu
de personnes s'est passé il ya eu en
2010 un changement de régime pour les
mineurs et ben voilà pourquoi fallait il
ya vraiment trois années une ça ne
concerne que 1400 personnes
je ne comprends pas votre obstination à
vouloir créer des paperasses
supplémentaire parce que ça va c'est pas
ça va créer un bazar sans nom pour les
administrations pour trois années
alors vous qui nous répéter sans cesse
que vous il faut penser à tout le monde
ou quoi que ce soit mais pensez à ces
personnes dans les caisses de retraite
qui vont devoir gérer pour ces trois
années
enfin vous êtes en train de créer une
usine à gaz pour pour pas grand chose
parce que 1400 personnes pour 3 années
et encore dans les trois années il y
aura pas 1400 personnes réellement c'est
de bon sens de supprimer sa vie ça ne
concerne que très peu de gens et la loi
de 2010 a déjà modifié le régime des
retraites donc maintenant fin supprimés
c'est cet alinéa et il n'ya pas comment
a dérogé à la règle parce que enfin
vraiment sa savane ça ça ne va ça va ne
durait que trois ans et donc vous allez
modifier des logiciels vous allez former
des gens dans les caisses de retraite et
aider tout ça pour très peu de gens sur
trois ans vous vous rendez compte du
coût supplémentaire
je vous remercie monsieur brunel
simplement pour dire que le communisme
se porte bien et faites attention à vous
parce marque je reviens et donc nous
n'avons pas les mêmes valeurs que vous
nous sommes pour le partage des
richesses seul pour taxer le capital
c'est pas votre cas pour revenir aux
mineurs pour venir aux mineurs qui sont
importantes mais aussi pour revenir à la
genèse comme ça a été dit que la
jeunesse de monde pas effectivement de
savoir quelle est l'origine watts la
demande jeunesse elle demande de vivre
son avenir elle demande d'étudier elle
demande dû trouver du travail
voilà la jeunesse est c'est ça et puis
il voit la retraite à travers la vie de
leur famille leurs parents qui étaient
assez comme ça qu'ils découvrent le
système de retraite le vote ils peuvent
pas parce qu'il est pas con mis en place
pour les mineurs pour les mineures je
comprends pas parce que on a un gros
problème là de dialogue avec monsieur le
ministre qui dit que les affiliés
retraités au régime des mineurs s'est
pas concernés ça me pose un gros
problème parce que ça veut dire que dans
le cadre de ce régime de la sécurité
sociale des mineurs y aurait le régime
qu'ils continueraient d'exister pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir payer les retraites
des mineurs donc les ententes mille
mineurs à coût d'un milliard en sachant
aussi que à travers ce ce régime de
caisse de démineurs c'est aussi les
médecins des mineurs c'est aussi le les
pharmacies une mineure qui est aussi les
soins qui existe à travers tout ça donc
vous avez dit tout à l'heure pour la
comédie française on va prendre le temps
de discuter et ben nous on vous demande
pour les mineurs les 132 mineurs dont on
a raconté l'histoire monde aurait pu
aussi raconté 1941 1942 pendant pleine
guerre qui se mettent tous en grève pour
réclamer notamment du savon et du pain
ça c'était aussi une grève importante et
à la fin de la guerre
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait en un an
dominèrent de retourner au fond pourquoi
faire pour pouvoir donner un maximum de
tonnes de charbon parce que le pays
avait plus rien ja ils l'ont fait mais
aujourd'hui on dit un terminé on n'a
plus besoin de vous vous allez rejoindre
notre régime ils ont ce régime là il
faut le garder
n'ayez pas peur de discuter avec eux
vous à le cléac'h la comédie française
tant mieux pour la comédie française
mais là vous n'êtes pas le droit
d'effacer comme ça d'un coup de crayon
ce régime qui existent bien et qui vous
demande pas beaucoup d'efforts commercy
un seul présent vizier mais merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voulais également avec le
groupe soutenir l'amendement thibault
besoin parce que franchement il ya des
moments où il faut savoir faire un geste
est ce que pour ces trois années c'est
vital le régime il n'existe plus il
était mis en extinction 2010 vous savez
très bien où vous avez ça coûte un peu
d'argent c'est vrai mais il ya des
symboles dessus il ya des symboles et
c'est très très bien dit d'ailleurs par
notre collègue janicot tout à l'heure
voyez moi j'ai grandi à haute voix
et il y avait les bassins miniers et
l'espérance de vie là bas je peux vous
dire monsieur le ministre
c'était dix ans de moins lorsqu'il y
avait la mine et ça faut pas l'oublier
et donc on doit quelque chose à cette
corporation qui a tant donné qui attend
payer et puis j'entends ce qu'a dit
nicolas turcotte tout à l'heure je les
écoute toujours avec beaucoup
d'attention
on a voulu faire un régime universel
donc on veut pas déroger
mais pour le personnel navigant vous
avez bien lâché en disant qu'à 60 ans
c'est une retraite à taux plein ça coûte
de l'argent va pas se raconter
d'histoires entre nous et vous avez bien
et c'est un régime complémentaire même
si les fondus dans le rêve donc il est
des moments où il faut savoir se
retrouver sur des symboles comme celui
là sinon quelque part où vous verrez que
cette profession qui a déjà payé un
cheikh tribut à notre pays se trouvera
une fois de plus martyrisé bien nous
pouvons donc passer au vote
je vous rappelle que c'est un scrutin
public que ces amendements ont reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement
je mets donc on voit l'amendement 14,99
est identique le scrutin est ouvert
il est clos soixante cinq votants
majorité 32 pour 23 contre 40 il est
donc rejeté
nous passons à l'article 18 814 est
identique sur lequel je saisis d'un
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe la france insoumise qui défend le
18 800 enfin les 17 amendements
identiques 18 814 madame panneaux merci
monsieur le président alors là on est
sur un régime qui concerne lui aussi
extrêmement peu de monde qui va
s'éteindre
donc comme on le disait tout à l'heure
pour les mineurs qui est un régime qui
est liée à l'histoire puisque on parle
du port autonome de strasbourg qui
s'appelait avant le port rhénan qui
existait au début du qe2 puis au début
du 20e siècle à l'époque où l'alsace
était allemande et qui est un régime
complètement indépendant qui ne coûte
absolument rien aux personnes
extérieures du port qui a sans
subventions d'état et où déjà depuis
les nouvelles personnes qui travaillent
cotisent au régime général
donc on parle de 137 personnes plusieurs
dizaines de salariés sur ses 137
cotisants ont fait grève le 5 pour vous
dire leur angoisse de voir alors qu'ils
sont un vieillissant ce régime changé et
il s'étonne d'ailleurs et je partage
leur étonnement ici pour vous le
transmed monsieur le ministre
puisque le gouvernement a communiqué
pour dire que tous les régimes spéciaux
avaient été sondés par le gouvernement
mais personne n'a pris le temps de
prendre contact avec la délégation
syndicale du port autonome de strasbourg
alors il s'en étonne peut-être sont-ils
trop petit ou en tout cas nous demandons
à ce que ne fasse pas disparaître ce
système qui va disparaître de lui-même
et que les 137 cotisants encore à ce
régime puisse terminer leur carrière et
avoir leur retraite en toute
tranquillité je vous remercie nous
passons à l'amendement 25
185 monsieur petiet mes positions de
principe saint laurent qui va défendre
le sort des salariés de strasbourg dans
un mouvement grand test de solidarité
vous l'avez compris c'est un amendement
d'appel l'avait dit il ya peu de monde
mais c'est une question de principe
si on doit tout remettre à plat il faut
le faire complètement et c'est ce que
cette loi ne permet pas tout ce qu'on a
fait c'est du colmatage c'est des
opérations shadoks sur des baisses de
cotisations qui doivent compenser aider
ça justement on n'a aucune visibilité
on est sur une politique shadoks on
pompe au repos etc on ne sait pas où on
va on a pas de visite et financière on a
pas d'acte cardinal pour nous dire
quelles sont les règles qui vont
présager à la transition et qui vont
faire plus de justice à la fin qu'au
début et c'est pour cette raison de
principes commandement d'appel est posée
par le groupe socialiste en soldat était
avec des hommes et des femmes du port de
strasbourg
je vous remercie sur les 16 amendements
26 757 est identique monsieur peu merci
monsieur le président très rapidement
pour dire que c'est la même position
c'est à la fois une position de principe
et puis ça franchement ça n'a pas de
sens il ya actuellement deux cents ans
retraité il ya 180 travailleurs
cotisants ça ne coûte rien aux caisses
de l'état est par ailleurs depuis 2015
c'est un régime qui va s'éteindre de
lui-même donc ça n'a pas de sens sauf à
vouloir vraiment faire passer tout le
monde sous la toise et à rendre
compliqué ce qui est simple ça n'a aucun
sens de revenir sur ce régime cher que
la guérilla
il ya un certain brouhaha qui est assez
désagréable je vous invite à bien
l'écouter l'orateur c'est pas parce
qu'on parle de strasbourg que je vous
demande ça mais je me demande quand même
un peu de découpe
monsieur selon un porte-parole
merci monsieur le président mais je sais
pas si justement j'ai sur mesure de
parler de strasbourg sous votre autorité
est-ce qu'on a un souvenir que récemment
encore le port de bordeaux avait un
régime autonome de retraite les ports
avait un régime autonome et est-ce que
ça a du sens d'avoir un régime autonome
pour 150 quotidiens
c'est la question qu'il faut se poser
est pour autant pour rebondir sur le
sujet précédent
j'ai écouté avec attention parce que les
députés qui se sont exprimés sur les
mines je sentais bien qu'il y avait
aussi une histoire de leur bassin de
l'eure qui était très forte et il faut
je deviens j'avais à côté de moi madame
la présidente qui me parle de aussi de
l'histoire de son territoire et
forcément c'est des expériences j'ai pas
j'ai pas cette opportunité face sur mon
territoire n'y a pas deux il ya pas de
mine mais je vois bien l'histoire qui
est derrière et pour autant
l'intégration dans le régime universel
c'est pas la négation de l'histoire
c'est justement tout ces corporations
qui ont su s'organiser qui ont été même
précurseur finalement de la sécurité
sociale par leur structuration elles se
sont structurées autour de règles
similaires mais se met parfois
différentes et que la et fasse sens
commun pour offrir ça à l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens
je trouve que ça a du sens et quelque
part c'est dans les régions minières les
fils et filles de mineurs qui font
aujourd'hui médecin je sais pas
informaticien
et tous les métiers qu'on trouve comme
dans d'autres territoires ce sont les
fils et filles d'agriculteurs ce sont
ces métiers là qui ont construit la
france telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui et je trouve que ça a du
sens que tous ces métiers se retrouvent
et et assume aussi les droits acquis par
le passé il a en eau pure aucun cas
question de revenir sur sur les droits
acquis pour c'est pour ces pour ces
professions là mais simplement de faire
sens et de fer unités sur les métiers et
comme l'a très bien dit notre collègue
opéré à tout à l'heure
effectivement les jeunes nos jeunes et
je crois qu'on pourrait l'appliquer à
nous quand on avait 20 ans quand on
avait 30 ans s'était pas enfin je ne
sais pas qui parmi vous pensé à ce
moment là à ses conditions de départ en
retraite et donc je crois que c'est un
faux débat à ce moment là et je crois
que c'est justement notre l'enjeu un des
enjeux de cette réforme c'est de
permettre à chacun quelles que soient
ses choix de carrière qu'ils fassent de
s'assurer qu'il aura des conditions de
départ en retraite équitable quel que
soit ce qu'il a pu faire exactement
selon merci monsieur ministre oui merci
monsieur le président j'ai un avis
défavorable aussi je crois que le
rapporteur a bien expliqué à la fois les
enjeux les deux sociétés mais aussi sur
le fond les enjeux par rapport au nombre
de personnes qui sont concernées
bon on a on avait la question tout à
l'heure aussi quand on se posait la
question du nombre de personnes qui
pourraient être concernées dans le cadre
du régime des mines le régime du port
autonome de strasbourg
il a son histoire il concerne peu de
monde seules 30 personnes seront
concernées par ce système universel
je dirais que on voit bien qu'il y à
toute la place pour ses trente personnes
dans le système universel voilà des
autres ports autonomes on l'a dit tout à
l'heure on fermait le régime
ce sera si vous ont décidé ainsi moi je
souhaite la même chose pour le port
autonome de strasbourg et on fera pour
ce régime spécial comme pour tous les
autres
on prendra le temps de la transition en
créant le chemin de convergence utile
pour rapprocher les droits de ceux qui
seront dans le système universel voilà
donc je vous invite
mesdames messieurs député repousser cet
amendement est en tout cas pour ceux qui
le présentent ou à le retirer a des fois
ne lui faudra non merci monsieur le
ministre comment pourrais-je faire
autrement que de passer la parole à
tirer michel ce qu'il l'a demandé merci
monsieur le président alors sans nul
doute le port autonome de strasbourg est
une réelle fierté pour la ville on pour
tous ici et je remercie évidemment ces
agents qui dotent strasbourg d'une
infrastructure portuaire efficace qu'en
fait le deuxième port fluvial français
un atout essentiel de son attractivité
économique
toutefois pourquoi strasbourg devrait
être la seule ville de france dont les
salariés du port bénéficient d'un régime
spécial de retraite est d'ailleurs un
service à la ronde
alors entre que de le pérenniser
rappelle aujourd'hui qui à 0,75 actifs
pour pour un retraité
et l'argument suivant lequel finalement
ça ne coûte rien à personne
il faut bien que le port assume assume
ses retraités donc ça coûte bien quelque
chose au bord donc nul besoin
d'argumenter plus longtemps vous
remonterez l'impasse dans lequel ce
régime va se trouver pour ça que
l'intégration des salariés du port
autonome de strasbourg dans le système
universel permettra la solidarité
nationale de s'exercer pleinement en
liant tous les assurés français les uns
aux autres et en ouvrant aux salariés
strasbourg les dispositifs de justice
sociale nouveau que nous créons comme
l'extension du compte pénibilité ou les
droits familiaux rénové je vous remercie
je vous remercie
c'est assez incompréhensible ce que
vient de dire notre notre collègue à
l'instant parce que non ce régime ne va
pas se retrouver dans une impasse
puisqu'il va s'éteindre de soi même
puisque déjà depuis 2015 les salariés
sont intégrés aux au régime général donc
donc en fait là on parle concrètement
237 cotisants vous dit
trente personnes qui seront concernées
par la retraite à points mais il n'y
aura pas une impasse comme vous êtes en
train de dire
et ce n'est pas la seule ville de france
où il n'ya pas le régime général puisque
actuellement lyell régime général qui
s'impose à ses salariés donc ça c'est la
première des choses
la deuxième des choses qui est
incompréhensible monsieur le rapporteur
c'est lorsque vous dites on ne revient
pas sur les droits acquis ah si vous
revenez sur des droits acquis ces
personnes-là 737 personnes là elle était
dans un régime qui jusqu'à leur durée et
qui s'est arrêtée en 2015
est ce que nous demandons c'est que ces
137 personnes puissent continuer dans la
continuité de ce qui avait été fait
auparavant
même si vous avez bien compris on se bat
pour que personne n'ait à faire à votre
retraite à points et puis la dernière
chose sur lequel vous n'avez pas répondu
quand même monsieur le ministre c'est
que lorsque les salariés demandent
pourquoi lorsque le gouvernement dit
qu'il a pris contact avec tous les
régimes spéciaux les syndics les
syndicats des régimes spéciaux qui ont
été sondés par le gouvernement vous
n'avez pas pris contact avec la
délégation syndicale du port autonome de
strasbourg j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi je vous remercie pas d'autres
prises de paroles nous pouvons donc
passer aux votes sur les amendements
sommes à pardon madame du billet chez
moi à l'excuser moi madame du billet
château lagueloup merci monsieur le
président je serais rapide sur ces deux
points que nous venons d'examiner à la
fois les mines et le port autonome de
strasbourg on a bien compris que
c'étaient des régimes en voie
d'extinction
je pense monsieur le ministre parce
qu'on a eu l'expérience avec le rsi
l'expérience avec louvois je suis pas du
tout sûr que tous les systèmes
informatiques aujourd'hui sont inter
qu'on est vraiment une interopérabilité
et une compatibilité au niveau des
de tout ce que l'on veut mettre dans un
système unique alors puisque ces deux
régimes sont en voie d'extinction qu'il
n'y aura pas de nouveau assuré qu'ils
vont arriver
je crois vraiment que au moins pour eux
qu'on évite ce type d'embêtements
je vous remercie cette fois ci nous
pouvons procéder au scrutin je vais donc
on voit le 18 814 à l'identique vous
avez regagner vos places le scrutin est
ouvert
il est clos 66 votants majorité 32 pour
10 contre 53 ils sont donc rejetées nous
passons une série d'amendements
identiques sur lequel je crois je n'ai
pas de scrutin public donc 17
amendements identiques 18 831 est
identique qui le défend ce matin ça vous
qu'ils défendent et qu'il est défendu
oui monsieur le président mes chers
collègues c'est un amendement de
suppression qui a pour motivation deux
éléments que vous allez fort bien
comprendre le premier c'est que de façon
assez systématique comme nous nous
opposons à votre loi nous refusons
l'intégration de chaque régime spéciaux
dans le régime général à point c'est une
position de principe
et là il se trouve que nous avons un
deuxième argument puisqu'il s'agit de
personnel cléricaux qui sont engagés
paix rémunérés par l'état dans le cadre
d'un héritage historique d'une certaine
manière qui est le concordat et nous
pensons que peut-être que le temps est
venu de s'interroger sur ce concordat en
conformité d'une certaine manière avec
nos principes de laïcité qui vise à la
séparation des églises et de l'état
et c'est un deuxième argument auquel
nous tenons puisque vous comprendrez
bien que il est compliqué d'expliquer
dans notre pays que nous rémunérons des
personnels des hommes d'église avec de
l'argent public qui sont donc payés
comme des agents de l'état et que
évidemment dès lors qu'on change le
système de retraite
on l'appliqué à ces personnels qui sont
de fait assimilé à des personnels à des
personnels d'état donc nous sommes là
face à un double problème est donc
double raison de demander la suppression
de cet article
cette année là dans la je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur mère 36 et il
défendu le 25 186 défendu je vous
remercie et le 26 758 monsieur brunel a
visualisé voici les mineurs et les
cultes - d'accord donc ceux présentement
vise à préserver le régime de retraite
des cultes et les membres des
congrégations et des collectivités
religieuses bon rappelons que c'est une
loi en date du 2 janvier 1978 qui a été
créé le régime social des cultes
bouclant ainsi le mouvement de
généralisation de protection sociale
entamée en france en 1945 alors c'est la
loi de 1978 elle a permis au culte
d'intégrer le régime général de la
sécurité sociale
chose qui fait tout en préservant leurs
spécificités
deux caisses avaient été créés
initialement l'une pour la maladie et
l'autre pour la retraite avant d'être
fusionné en 1999 dans la caisse
d'assurance vieillesse invalidité et
maladies des cultes certes aujourd'hui
sur le fond de le régime des cultes est
totalement aligné sur celui des salariés
du privé depuis 1998 les droits les
cotisations les calculs pour le montant
des pensions sont exactement les mêmes
restent en reste deux caractéristiques
propres au régime la majorité des
assurés mettant leurs revenus en commun
il été décidé que chacun perret des
cotisations sur une assiette forfaitaire
équivalente à une rémunération au smic
même si la plupart n'atteignent pas ce
niveau de rénumération le salaire d'un
prêtre s'élève en effet à 980 à 945
euros par mois
en contrepartie de cette ponction
importante en termes de cotisations des
assurés perçoivent les pension calculée
sur la base d'un smic ce qui permet de
relever le niveau des pensions deuxième
spécificité la cessation d'activité qui
n'a pas vraiment de sens dans la
prêtrise
or pour obtenir ses droits à la retraite
un salarié du privé ou un indépendant
doit apporter la preuve d'une cessation
d'activité pendant six mois
c'est enfin que le gouvernement veille à
ce que ce soit préservée ces deux
caractéristiques propres au culte que
nous avons déposé cet amendement de
suppression qui en réalité un amendement
d'appel à ce que l'exécutif se montrent
attentifs à ces situations bien
particulières
si monsieur le rapporteur oui merci
monsieur le président donc sur la
suppression du régime de retraite du
culte liés au concordat j'entends votre
remarque madame autun sur notamment le
le le la laïcité de l'état français donc
fut l'argumentaire moi je crois qu'il
faut respecter respecter une histoire et
qui plus est liée à une histoire
particulièrement douloureuse et comme
pour tout pour tous les régimes de
retraite favoriser leur intégration dans
ce système universel donc des fois je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est vrai
que le concordat là il prévu des
dispositions qui sont assez spécifique
puisque en fait pour les populations qui
sont concernés par cet alinéa la
retraite intervient uniquement en cas
d'inaptitude donc les dispositions sont
très différentes de ce que nous
connaissons habituellement et il faut
considérer cela
aujourd'hui on parle pas pour l'ensemble
des autres citoyens concernés de
retraite uniquement au monde inaptitude
donc on a la nécessité de regarder les
modalités de prise en charge des
cotisations
du coup et des conditions spéciales de
départ qui sont liées au droit local qui
doivent être maintenues avec un
amendement sur laquelle on aura sans
aucun doute l'occasion de venir au sénat
donc tu ce sujet sera donc complétée
ultérieurement dans le cadre de la
navette de ce texte
voilà je vous invite les messieurs les
députés ont repoussé c'est un moment et
à laisser faire les concertations sur le
sujet je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président d'alors joie
et salué la volonté nos collègues
communistes de sauvegarder le régime de
retraite des cultes c'est assez drôle
mais pour aller saluer pour ça et pour
cette ouverture d'esprit cette cohérence
non je voudrais prendre la parole
monsieur le président parce que nous
venons de passer une barre symbolique
des 30 mille amendements ça
effectivement peut saluer je voulais
dire que nous sommes en séance depuis
maintenant sans 17h sur cette cette loi
et quand on compare la durée de ce débat
avec les débats sous les différentes
natures de la vème république on est
déjà déjà dans les diluants dont les
débats ont été les plus longs c'est deux
fois le temps de la loi sur les
retraites de 2010 par exemple essayez de
loin de plus loin je suis désolé c'est
quand même on vient de passer la barre
des 30 minutes je peux le signifier
c'est important précisé aussi que nous
sommes nous sommes à 10 % des articles
et nous sommes à 14% des amendements de
cette loi alors que nous sommes déjà à
110 7 heures
je voudrais redire que nous souhaitons
nous aller jusqu'au bout de la lecture
et de l'examen de cette loi qu'il faut
être cependant raisonnable et que pour
arriver au bout de cette loi nous devons
absolument supprimer les amendements qui
sont des amendements de forme pour nous
concentrer sur les amendements qui
viennent de tous les bords qui viennent
de tous les rangs et qui nous
permettraient
et d'améliorer cette loi merci beaucoup
je vous remercie bien j'ai plusieurs
demandes de prise de parole y at il des
prises de parole concernant le concordat
est le sujet d'un moment ou pas du tout
parce que évidemment c'est frustrant
d'être proches au perchoir et de ne pas
pouvoir en parler mais personne ne veut
parler de l'amendement et du seuil de
l'amendement est ce qu'il ya plusieurs
prises de parole madame autun monsieur
petit frère monsieur vigier vous
souhaitez intervenir
madame autun j'aime bien la façon dont
vous avez introduit votre question pour
savoir de quoi on voulait parler vous
parlez bien du concordat est précisément
s'il ya un sujet sur lequel je n'ai pas
eu de réponse d'être ministre ligny du
ministre du rapporteur c'est sur le
concordat
j'ai eu des réponses sur le fait qu' on
allait basculer le régime etc et les
raisons pour lesquelles ça concernait
peu de monde mais sur le point de vue
notamment du gouvernement parce qu'elle
est limite dont le rapporteur sur la
loire retraite qu'il un point de vue sur
le concordat il y en a sans doute un à
titre personnel mais qui restait pas
exactement le sujet en revanche le
ministre peut être peut s'exprimer sur
ce point et je profite d'avoir la parole
pour malgré tout rebondir sur un point
c'est que à plusieurs reprises depuis le
début de ce débat j'ai été ce moment le
micro mme a été coupée où j'ai été
fermement rabrouer par un président ou
une présidente un président en général
deux séances qui me dit vous parler de
quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'amendement et je constate qu'il ya
deux poids deux mesures que bien souvent
ils arrivent à les députés de la
république en match de parler de quelque
chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'amendement je n'en fais pas reproche
je n'en fais pas reproches et il a
parfaitement le droit à un moment donné
de dire ce qu'il a envie de dire sur le
sujet qui lui paraît à ce moment-là
important mais je veux juste qu'on
prendre à témoin l'ensemble des députés
présents ici pour dire qu' il ne peut
pas y avoir deux poids deux mesures on
peut pas ce matin me couper le micro
parce que je parle de jacques maire
excellent sujet et laisser un député de
la république en main nous parler du
nombre d'amendements lac c'est
absolument pas le sujet du moment
je demande juste un minimum un minimum
de règles démocratiques qui s'applique à
l'ensemble des députés et pas des règles
qui soit à géométrie variable en
fonction de l'intérêt de la majorité de
cette assemblée si simplement une petite
précision je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez l'article 54.6 mais
effectivement il dispose que l'orateur
ne doit pas s'écarter de la question on
peut pas considérer que nos débats
depuis deux semaines et était une
stricte adéquation entre les thèmes
abordés et le fonds des amendements donc
c'est un article n'a pas été appliquées
effectivement à la lettre sinon on
aurait parlé uniquement de l'amendement
en question
donc il faut l'apprécier à chaque fois
et chaque président l'a apprécié comme
il comme il le souhaite le peu le veut
donc on a plusieurs interventions
monsieur peut nous avons une demande de
parole de monsieur vizier je crois que
c'était dans l'ordre
monsieur peu puis monsieur vigier je
couvrais oui monsieur le président
j'espère que vous me je ne peux pas ne
pas répondre j'étais un an nous avons
été pas moi personnellement nous avons
été interpellés par monsieur 15,9 sur
pourquoi les communistes défendre cet
amendement sur les cultes comme si ça s
c'était une hérésie alors d'abord
d'abord vous savez mais mais on se
faisait la remarque tout à l'heure que
des fois c'était les débats un tout
petit peu historique avait prenez deux
parfois des tournures bizarre dans cet
hémicycle et jeffrey l'auf en sa
personne de de ne pas suffisamment
s'inspirer de l'histoire politique de
notre pays mais enfin vous savez aragon
quand il a raconté dans ce merveilleux
poème la rose et le réséda l'histoire de
la résistance en france il parlait de
ceux qui croyaient au ciel et ceux qui
n'y croyaient pas pour parler des de la
multitude delà de la résistance
je suis d'une villa saint denis où yann
basilic et ou de tout temps l'évêché de
saint denis a été l'évêché qui dans
l'épiscopat français était chargé des
relations avec le mouvement ouvrier nous
avons accueilli en 1982 le maire
communiste de saint denis et j'ai été
jeune militant à l'époque nous avons
accueilli le pape qui venait fêter les
50 ans de la jeunesse ouvrière
chrétienne dans la basilique de
saint-denis et le pape a parlé devant un
calicot immense où c'était marqué la vie
d'un jeune travailleur vaut plus
tout l'or du monde il ya dans ma ville
18 prêtre ouvrier une histoire de
l'action catholique ouvrière extrêmement
importante c'est aussi ça l'histoire du
mouvement ouvrier des communistes qui
avec les chrétiens ont su se retrouver
dans la résistance dans les luttes
sociales et donc je demanderai à nos
collègues d'avoir un peu plus
d'épaisseur historique pour juger de ces
affaires là que la vision de peppone et
don camillo
je vous remercie monsieur vigier et
monsieur petit jeu très rapidement
puisque notre collègue peut élever le
débat avec les l'abbé peu oui avec les
références historiques et moi je lui en
donne acte seulement dire à notre
collègue cazeneuve je trouve qu'il y
avait un peu un esprit de gourmandise
lorsqu'il expliquait qu on est juste des
franchises les 30000 vendu on a tous
envie d'aller au bout du texte tous ils
pouvaient pas nous accuser de faire de
l'obstruction donc simplement laissons
aller les choses remettait pas des sous
dans la fente et dans le jackpot
avançons travaillons sérieusement
monsieur petit avant de parler du
concordat moi j'ai entendu surtout
compte demander aussi peut-être pour
accélérer d'enlever un certain nombre
d'amendements qui sont des amendements
très frustrant à discuter maintenant je
veux revenir sur le concordat moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec des
analyses historiques et g10 m'est arrivé
plusieurs fois parce que cette
discussion sur le concordat en
particulier avec la france insoumise et
quelque chose qui revient souvent
je voudrais d'abord dire que moi j'ai
été élevé dans cette région je pense pas
que ce soit une région soit plus au
moins libre - laïque ou plus laïque plus
neutres qu'ailleurs et puis j'aurais
quand même rappeler quelque chose qui a
trait à des événements assez récent dans
notre pays un débat qui est présent
aujourd'hui dans le pays
c'est que le concordat en alsace moselle
il a été décidé par un référendum
1921 il ya un référendum ou à une énorme
majorité on décide de maintenir le
concordat mais là la question mais mais
je vous attendais chers collègues
la question était assez simple êtes vous
pour le maintien du concordat puisqu'on
venait de revenir en france
je vous rappelle que le au moment de
l'abolition du concordat
d'alsace-moselle n'était pas en france
donc quand l'alsace moselle décide de
revenir en france
le concordat y est toujours et on
demande trois ans après la fin de la
guerre on demande aux alsaciens
mosellans voulez vous maintenir le
concordat ou non et les politiques à
cette époque
sachant très bien poser une question de
référendaire pour pas faire de bêtises
savait très bien qu'il fallait que le
concordat sont maintenues pour que
l'alsace moselle décide de revenir en
france sinon on aurait on avait peur du
contraire et donc par rapport à la
question référendaire qu'il faudrait
poser sur cette réforme
je pense et c'était nos arguments cette
époque là il y a une il ya son sont 17
heures c'était que la question
référendaire serait un peu plus
compliqué pour nous mais je tenais quand
même à rappeler que la décision de
rester dans le concordat c'est une
décision référé par référendum des
alsaciens mosellans
je remercie madame du monde merci
monsieur le président je ne reviendrai
pas sur le concordat mais un petit d'un
mot sur les propos de monsieur 15,9
effectivement le collègue peu a dit ce
qu'il fallait sur ses propos incroyable
et invoquant un besoin d'épaisseur
historique
j'ai bien apprécié l'expression mais je
crois monsieur chère collègue 15 mais il
faudrait aussi vous essayer un petit peu
d'épaisseur démocratique peut-être quand
vous dites ici dans l'hémicycle qu'il
faudrait supprimer des amendements non
mais c'est surréaliste c'est
invraisemblable il faut vous intégriez
que le droit d'amendement et le droit
essentiel d'un parlementaire a fortiori
de l'opposition donc un parlementaire un
député nous deux demandes comme ça il
faudrait supprimer des amendements c'est
proprement surréaliste
[Applaudissements]
bien monsieur reds elle oui merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le président quelques
mots par rapport à ce qui a été dit par
monsieur petit il a insisté sur le fait
qu' effectivement 1921 la question du
concordat été tranchée par un référendum
et il faut que ça chez nous sommes un
certain nombre à être élus des
départements d'alsace et de moselle
si nous interrogeons aujourd'hui la
population
je puis vous assurer que le résultat
serait strictement le même et donc
lorsque l'on entend parfois
effectivement des collègues qui disent
il faudrait supprimer le concordat je
pense qu'ils ne se rendent pas compte
quel est le degré d'attachement
notamment des alsaciens mosellans à
cette question il ya deux sujets qui
sont des sujets très fort le droit local
en général et le concordat
spécifiquement et là aussi quand on se
réclame d'une vision démocratique
vouloir le bien des gens à leur place
c'est assez inquiétant alors j'ai une
demande de suspension de séance mais
j'ai un rappel au règlement
et j'ai un vote à faire avant la
suspension de séance donc on va faire
d'abord le récit est présent chez peau
de mise en cause personnelle ait pas
d'ambiguïté par rapport à ce que je dis
depuis toujours de manière absolument
constante
nous voulons aller jusqu'au bout de ce
texte 2 2 nous voulons absolument passer
du temps sur les amendements qui
permettent de faire évoluer les
abonnements qui sont constructifs les
amendements qui vont nous permettre de
faire progresser cette loi mais
franchement si on veut aller jusqu'au
bout sereinement est-ce que nous sommes
obligés de voir autant d'amendements
point virgule synonyme de ford
la réponse elle éclaire le plein non
donc oui au droit d'amendement
mais attention à l'obstruction bien nous
allons pouvoir sirpa d'autres prises de
parole sur le fond choix que chaque
groupe qu'il souhaitait s'est exprimé
nous allons procéder au vote et nous
ferons une interruption de séance à
votre demande juste après si on voulait
bien nous passons donc merci pour ces
moments alsacien en tout cas nous
passons donc au scrutin sur l'amendement
10 848 est identique vous avez gagnez
vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
attendez je mets une fiche
oui vous avez raison c'est à main levée
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est donc visiblement rejeté
suspension de séance pour cinq minutes
bien
prenons nos travaux avec l'amendement
les amendements 10 848 est identique sur
lequel je suis saisi par la france
insoumise d'une demande de scrutin
public que nous annonçons alors le 18
800 ha mince pardon le trottola le 18 2
ouais c'est pas très courtois mais alors
ils ne sont pas défendus une fois deux
fois trois fois donc le 18 840 8 et 10
les 17 amendements identiques ne sont
pas défendus nouvelle 125 100 87 25
défendu je remercie et nous passons aux
26 759 non plus pas défendu bon attendez
vous vous lavez défendu un vous avez dit
défendu donc monsieur le rapporteur quel
est votre avis défavorable c'est une
mine east même avis que le rapporteur
monsieur cousineau remercie pas de prise
de parole
nous passons alors du coup nous passons
au vote
c'est un scrutin public je vous rappelle
sur les dix-huit 848 1,11 vers des
niveaux place
le scrutin est ouvert
il est clos
32 votants 28 exprimé pour 3 contre 25
ils sont donc rejeter passes en 25 100
88 qui défendent en groupe socialiste le
25 188 cyr collègues restons concentrés
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable monsieur le ministre mais ma
vie quelqu'un soit il prend la parole
non nous passons donc aux votes sur 25
188 à main levée qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté nous passons 39,08 sur une
série d'amendements identiques il n'est
pas défendu le 25 248 et il défendu
pardon
s'il ya dessinateur dans la salle mais
vous ne défendez pas bon il n'est pas
défendu le 26 850 2 monsieur brunel
c'est vous qui le défendent et 16
amendements identiques
non non non ne parlait pas la place de
monsieur brunel qui porte la
responsabilité voilà où se peut nous
sommes sur le 26 je vous remercie à
alesi allez-y je croyais que c'était le
aucun problème celui d'avant non celui
ci on va on va le défendre d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un amendement que nous
nous défendons pour protéger les marins
et les professions de mer contre ce
mauvais projet de loi le monde maritime
est un monde très particulier on a eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure dont le régime de retraite est
l'héritier d'un compromis historique
créée sous colbert
ses racines sont demeurées intactes
jusqu'à aujourd'hui les marins mérite
mieux qu'une réforme a trop et les
marins ont besoin de savoir ce qu'il ya
des ordonnances qui les concernent et
des questions qui se posent et qui pour
l'instant n'ont pas de réponse et donc
il y en a au moins quatre qu'on
souhaiterait vous posez en leur nom oui
ou non les marins pourront ils continuer
de bénéficier de leurs pensions
d'ancienneté des 50 ans lorsqu'ils ont
effectué plus de 25 ans de service en
mer c'est une question très concrète
oui ou non pourront ils encore bénéficié
de départ à la retraite anticipé dès 55
ans après quinze années de service en
mer oui ou non leur pension soir at elle
toujours calculées sur le salaire
forfaitaire de la profession tout ça
sont des inconnus des questions qu'ils
ont posées par lesquels ils ont pas eu
de réponse pour l'instant
oui ou non leur période de cotisation
inclure at elle encore les périodes de
congés de repos d'accidents des périodes
de chômage les périodes de service
militaire sont autant de questions très
précises que posent les marins par
rapport à l'évolution de leur régime de
retraite auquel ils n'ont pas eu de
réponse pour l'instant
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous déposons cet amendement monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président donc nous
sommes tous attachés à la préservation
d'un régime spécifique pour les assurés
marin cet attachement se manifeste déjà
par l'existence d'un cinquième régime on
a parlé du régime universel du système
universel et d5 régime d'affiliation
donc à un régime spécifique lié aux
marins là la situation spécifique des
marins sera renverra une habilitation à
légiférer par ordonnances parce qu'elles
concernent d'abord des statuts
différents et je remercie mon collègue
jimmy pahun qui m'a fait rencontrer des
représentants des des régimes actuels de
sécurité sociale de la marine qui sont
qui recouvre des différentes des
structures différentes suivant qu'on
soit de la main marine marchande de la
marine de plaisance ce don kelly et des
situations très spécifiques et donc il
faut en tenir compte
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement choisi
de légiférer par ordonnances pour tenir
compte et construire progressivement les
solutions qui s'appliqueront à tous donc
je ne me permettrais pas de donner des
réponses aux questions précises que vous
avez posé parce que je pense que les
équilibres peut-être le ministre dira
demont mais déséquilibre ne sont pas
encore acté je peux simplement précisé
que l'objectif n'est ni de revenir sur
le départ anticipé à la retraite des
marins ni de supprimer les nîmes
l'établissement national des invalides
de la marine en revanche intégration
dans le si dans le champ du système
universel et le calcul des retraites à
partir du point comme unité sont deux
avancées qui nous semble acceptable et
pragmatique mais défavorables à votre
amendement thiam ministre monsieur le
président je le député peut assez c'est
un petit peu un exercice très positif
monsieur le président parce que j'ai dû
répondre de façon très très très
précises monsieur le fur qui m'avait
demandé au moins quatre reprises
de répondre à ces questions là donc je
les fais vraiment en prenant mon temps
donc je vais le faire aussi avec plaisir
pour vous parce qu'il n'ya pas de n'y a
pas de sujet mais comme il ya huit
groupes dans cette assemblée si j'ai
bien compris s'il faut que je le fasse
encore six fois le show troisième fois
qu'on me donne acte du fait que j'ai
répondu parce que je vois là je voudrais
pas qu'il ya un groupe qui prennent mal
le fait que je n'ai pas répondu à l'un
ou à l'autre donc sur sur la spécificité
des marins se débuter peu il faut
prendre en compte aussi et peut-être
d'abord l'environnement commercial dans
lequel les gens de la mer évolue ce soir
les pêcheurs ou la marine marchande et
il nous faut être attentif effectivement
à ce contexte contexte qui peut être
d'ailleurs parfois bouleverser comme on
le voit pour nos pêcheurs en ce moment
au niveau du bric sites et des zones de
pêche
donc j'ai pris un certain nombre
d'engagements et j'ai envoyé un courrier
aux organisations représentatives avec
jean-baptiste djebbari pour confirmer à
la fois que la concertation en cours
étaient orientés je crois très
clairement autour des attentes du monde
de la mer à la fois pour le maintien
denim ça a été dit tout à l'heure par le
rapporteur
c'est qu'elle est il y aura des
possibilités est clairement de
délégation de gestion et donc de
maintien dans une caisse qui soit un
interlocuteur direct pour les marins
l'accompagnement de l'état pour les
employeurs au travers du
notamment la concurrence internationale
auxquelles font face notamment la marine
marchande ou lady et donc la nécessité
d'être attentif aux assiette forfaitaire
aussi et les 55 ans pour faire droit à
son départ en retraite
avec quinze ans de mer donc ces
dispositions je les ai rappelés jeu
l'erreur rappel mais je vois là je
voulais que ça soit très transparent ce
soir et vous étiez peut-être là ou pas
mais ça n'est pas l'important je vous le
devez donc je le fais bien volontiers
monsieur le député et donc du coup moi
je vous proposerais bien de retirer
votre amendement parce que sur le fond
on est dans une situation où les marins
se verront préserver dans leur
spécificité avec un regard
particulièrement attentif du
gouvernement sur la concurrence
internationale auxquelles ils font face
dans un secteur particulièrement exposés
je vous remercie
qu'y at-il de prise de parole n'est
maintenant pas d'autres prises de parole
bien donc il ya pas de prise de parole
nous passons au vote qui est un vote à
main levée sur le 26 850 2 les 16
amendements identiques d'où l'avis
défavorable qui est pour et qui est
contre
ils sont donc rejetées l'an passé en 25
100 89
la dame du monde merci le président
monsieur le président un petit peu sur
le même sujet stéphane peu a bien
défendu la question de la spécificité du
régime des marins là il s'agit du
recours aux ordonnances
je reviens d'un mot sur le fait que
voilà qui a beaucoup beaucoup
d'ordonnancé dans ce texte beaucoup de
projets de décret que les autres réforme
des retraites ont pas eu besoin de
recourir à ça et nous on trouve
insupportable de se dessaisir ainsi de
notre responsabilité législatives alors
tout à l'heure on nous demande
d'abandonner des amendements là on nous
demande dans le texte de procéder par
ordonnance c'est pas notre conception de
la république parlementaire
et c'est inconcevable dans un texte
aussi important même si le régime des
marins est complexe mais je vous
rappelle tout de même monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs ça fait quoi deux ans donc
si vous n'êtes pas prêt à la limite on
peut l'entendre on l'entend d'ailleurs
tous les jours mais prenez le temps et
puis revenez quand vous le serez les
français d'ailleurs ont le droit de
savoir ce qui quand ça sortira de
l'assemblée nationale ce qu'il y aura
dans ce texte et non pas de renvoyer
comme ça à des ordonnances tout cela ne
contribue vraiment pas à la lisibilité
du texte ni à la prévisibilité des
effets de celui ci et donc disons qu'on
n'a pas non plus entièrement confiance
peut-être en tout cas on n'a pas envie
de parier quoi voilà donc je m'en remets
une fois de plus à ce que le conseil
d'état vous a dit et écrit dans le temps
d'ordonnancé il estime que le conseil
d'état que celles ci font perdre la
visibilité d'ensemble qui est nécessaire
à l'appréciation des conséquences de la
réforme et partant de sa
constitutionnalité et de sa
conventionalité quand le conseil d'état
a dit ça je pense qu'effectivement il
vaut mieux reprendre le travail en
interne du parlement et voir comment
faire le travail ici et non pas renvoyer
à des ordonnances merci je vous remercie
madame clémentine autain vous avez
demandé un rappel au règlement s'il vous
plaît chers collègues nous écoutons
madame autun le président c'est sur la
base de l'article 100 pour la sincérité
des débats
je me permets de faire remarquer à notre
assemblée que les arguments qui ont été
avancés tout à l'heure hors sujet comme
vous l'avez tous remarqué par monsieur
15,9 qui consistait à nous faire
remarquer que nous avions dépassé un
nombre d'études d'amendements assez
important et que le nombre d'heures que
nous avons d'ores et déjà passées à
discuter de cette loi nous plaçait dans
des records historiques de débat autour
d'une loi et il se trouve
j'ai vérifié avant de deux interpellés
notre assemblée il se trouve que ce sont
exactement les termes que nous avons pu
lire dans le monde
entendre sur france inter dans la bouche
d'un président de groupe de la majorité
exactement les arguments qui vise à
légitimer le recours à 1 49 3 c'est à
dire que ce que ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui dans la bouche de monsieur
cazeneuve est exactement mais pour mot
ce qui a été écrit dans la presse ce qui
a été dit à la radio pour légitimer le
recours aux 49 3 ce qui interpelle sur
la sincérité de nos débats parce que
l'un sincérité de nos débats c'est
pouvoir travailler en se disant que
jusqu'au bout des 65 article je veux
remercier nous passons nous reprenons le
fil de nos débats nous étions à
l'amendement 26 851 défendu je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur merci
monsieur le président pas d'élément
particulier par rapport à ce qu'a
indiqué monsieur le ministre sur
l'amendement précédent peut-être juste
resituer les enjeux en termes
démographiques
aujourd'hui les cotisants marin c'est
environ 30000 11500 qui relève de la
marine du commerce 16000 de la pêche et
2500 autres pour donc au total donc
trente mille pour cent neuf mille
passionnés dont 67 milles de droit
direct pour situer un petit peu les les
enjeux démographiques mais sur
l'amendement concerné défaveur east
merci monsieur le président je me suis
exprimé tout à l'heure je crois assez
longuement sur le sujet et des marins je
n'y reviendrai pas avis défavorable sur
président remercie at il des prises de
parole non scrutin à main levée double
avis défavorable qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté nous passons 26 1 853 16
amendements identiques
monsieur brunel
oui avec cet amendement
nous vous proposons de sorte de porte de
sortie de la casse sociale que vous
préparez à appliquer aux régimes de
retraite des marins car vous le savez
les marins ne sont pas dupes les
organisations syndicales elles aussi ne
le sont pas les négociations que vous
avez ouverte ne répondent pas leur
inquiétude
et ce n'est pas non plus une lettre
d'engagement qui fait force de loi
engagez-vous en renonçant à réformer son
régime des marins par ordonnance
vous avez souhaité apporter des
garanties mais des questions restent en
suspens comme l'application de l'âge
pivot et de ces professions il en est
question dans votre réforme si un âge
pivot entre en vigueur pour les marins
comment pouvez vous affirmer qu'ils
pourront continuer à partir des 55 ans
avec 15 ans d'ancienneté
comment seront traités les marins s'ils
n'atteignent pas cet âge pivot
comment sera-t-il défini et sur quelle
base les marins compte-t-on t-il une
décote alors qu'ils bénéficient d'un
droit de départ anticipé comment cela
pourra calculer l'âge pivot pour les
marins
pour un marin qui partirait en retraite
à 55 ans c'est à dire en 2027 avec un
âge pivot de 64 ans à combien de
pourcentage s'élèverait la décote votre
amateurisme c'est encore là toute sa
démonstration car là encore rien n'est
inscrit dans la loi ne privez pas les
marins d'un débat de fond sur ce sujet
expliquez vous sur le rapporteur
défavorable c'est les mêmes arguments
que tout à l'heure
monsieur le ministre est nommé avec le
rapporteur
monsieur petit
oui pour une fois je voudrais être et
soutenir la remarque de notre collègue
clémentine autain tout à l'heure je
trouve que c'est vrai c'est très
désagréable est très frustrant pour moi
que souvent on entend dans l'hémicycle
des mots cuisson qui ont tourné en
boucle sur les radios des choses qui
sont répéter répéter répéter de la même
manière et je trouve que tous nous
devrions faire attention je vous
remercie pas d'autres prises de parole
nous passons donc vote à main levée sur
le 26 853 pour les 16 amendements
identiques d'où l'avis défavorable et
pour lutter contre ils sont donc
rejetées
nous passons à une série d'amendements
identiques de 75 33 pas défendu le 76 08
ne me semble pas défendue non plus si à
me suicider pardon oui excusez moi c'est
pour habitude de rester un peu en
retrait monsieur le président monsieur
le minispace que système de retraite que
vous proposez n'est pas universelle et
qu'il comporte au moins cinq régimes
différents trois traitements
générationnel différents ainsi que des
dizaines de dérogations et d'exception
du fait de vos multiples reculade
nous souhaitons par respect pour les
français supprimer le terme universel
dans l'ensemble du texte vous remercie
le onze 911 ce matin faisait la part
merci monsieur le président j'aime
beaucoup répété cette phrase finalement
par souci de cohérence avec l'ensemble
de nos amendements
je pense qu'il serait bon de supprimer
le mot universel de ce texte merci je
vous remercie le 11 912 monsieur minots
merci monsieur le président
effectivement mes collègues se sont déjà
exprimés sur le sujet sur le moment de
de mon éminent collègue le furent il
sera donc défendu
puis je trafique monsieur le rapporteur
alors pour reprendre l'expression de
monsieur matin par souci de cohérence je
serais défavorable
monsieur le ministre vous c'est
sébastien jumel qui m'a démontré mon
micro faut réparer le sien quand ça
fonctionne
et oui oui c'est chez miche
je tiens à le préciser que c'était un à
titre très amicale que je me permettait
de faire ce stage vous ne voudrez pas
avoir non mais simplement sur le débat
je ferais cours monsieur le président ce
que je voulais dire sur le débat parce
qu'on revient sur le débat sur le mot
universel donc moi en tout cas j'ai bien
accuser réception que vous ne pensiez
pas que c'est universal j'espère que
vous avez bien compris que je défende
est un système universel dans lequel il
y avait cinq régimes défavorable je vous
remercie at il des commentaires non des
prises par al oui madame panneaux
et monsieur petit que le président juge
juste pour dire aux collègues petit qui
disait que c'était assez fatiguant que
des choses soient reprises à la radio
dans la presse écrite que quand même ce
que l'intervention que nous a fait tout
à l'heure le collègue cazeneuve
ressemble quand même sérieusement du
service commandé pour alimenter cette
petite musique du 49 3 je voulais juste
quelque chose quand même d'un député la
république en marche au monde qui dit
l'idée est de dépasser le record
d'heures passées dans l'hémicycle avant
de constater l'impossibilité d'adopter
le texte
149 3 ou encore monsieur le gendarme qui
disait il ya quelques jours à france
info
en début de semaine prochaine nous
battrons le record de durée d'un débat
parlementaire pendant la cinquième
république